hey julian
how are you so good drew i miss you
first and foremost and i hope you're
doing well i will say
for the record that every time i run
into julianne she is
literally the nicest person you could
ever meet on the planet
um and we feel the exact same way about
you you're the best
so i can see i i don't know julianne
that well but i
feel like i could velcro myself to her
um
at any given moment nina what was your
experience like when you met her
because you seem so cool so like speaks
to like
well yeah i agree i think energy
attracts energy and we have very
like-minded energy
and the way we met was through a mutual
friend
julian and i were both going through
life crisises at the time
and we were using that mutual friend as
a free therapist
kind of and it got to a degree where she
was so sick of hearing about our
problems that were very similar that she
was like okay i'm gonna put you guys
together and then you guys can use each
other for therapy
and i can remove myself and i feel like
you'll be best friends like she just
knew
and and she was right and we're still in
therapy to this day
we continue to be leaning on each other
in fact we had a slumber party last
night knowing we were coming here this
morning
um and sitting on my floor and drinking
our wine and just
having our good old girl chat so i don't
think there's really anything in life
that i haven't
gotten through overcome or even found
enjoyable through the fires
um because of my girlfriends there's
like nothing
that my girlfriends don't um amplify
in in just the meaning of life
it's a hundred percent true and i don't
know what i would do without my
girlfriends especially just
through this last pandemic and
everything and being able to come
together whether it's through zoom
through a glass of wine whatever it is
like um
they are the consistent thing in your
life and nina has definitely been that
that rock for me definitely especially
in in like early pandemic days
before we could see each other we would
do little little zoom dates kind of like
we're doing right now with you
and we would stay connected in that way
and then eventually once like it was
safe to be in a bubble we were each
other's bubble and then
we would bring the wine in person we
just really connected over that
and connected over being like going
through this together and
and having a shared partner because it's
so hard in this last year
so many people felt lack of connection
and it's one way to
to bring that to each other and be there
for each other yeah i also love the fact
that you guys came together with this
wine and you would drink it and talk
about it i want you to tell me
where was the light bulb moment of like
wait a minute
we have something to offer here how did
fresh
fine wine come about what was the aha
moment of we've got to do this
let's just say there's been years and
years of market research that we've been
doing
together and separately but mainly
together
and that that connection that we talked
about
this connection that we have it's always
been with a glass of wine in hand and
it's always been
like wine and just like having that
shared experience and it's all been
about experiences
and then one day we were like why don't
we why don't we bring this to the world
like this is so like
we have we see something that there's a
like a gap in the marketplace in a way
well and i think that that's the thing
it's like we're best friends
we have shared experiences we love to
travel we've
had such like a fortunate life to be
able to try
really amazing wines but at the same
time we're also like health fanatics and
so
we want to have a holistic approach to
everything that we do
and so we did see a gap in the market
where we were like wow
like people are trying to do healthy
wine but it tastes
like you know so we're how do we give
that same like
luxury premium experience because
everything is an experience it's not
just about the taste it's not
it's a sensory experience so how does it
smell how does it taste what's the
environment like we want to be able to
give
everyone the opportunity to have an ex
an exquisite
experience so it's a guilt-free
experience yes we really believe in
having a wonderful life and enjoying
life and also being healthy and having a
holistic approach to life so
and then doing finding that balance yeah
and doing that with people that you love
and you're connected to yeah
i'm so happy for you guys
you